it's resisting temptation well see this
is I think again what goes to the
natural system is that men are more
attracted to visually to visual
stimulation versus women is something
that's been proven over and over in
different areas so this is a way to help
them but it is not it's not a perfect
system they're supposed to pass and
they're supposed to do things and yeah
there's a whole list of things they're
supposed to go through and supposedly
the social penalty
remember in Islam you're not supposed to
have sex except within marriage so
that's like a huge thing that the West
doesn't have or maybe it does but in
certain yeah in certain particular areas
yeah so I mean you know but it's not a
common thing but in Islam this is the
whole point so to make sure that you
know you you retain that but the point
about men is that supposedly the
cultural and societal penalty is huge
for not for going outside of the
marriage robe actually doing something
like that
we've lost it unfortunately yes